what happens when you throw a bunch of
transforming cars transforming animals
and a planet eating World Ender into the
same movie a whole lot of confusing
moments let's dig into them
Transformers rise of the beasts opens
with a scene set on the maximal's home
planet we're introduced to Optimus
primal and his gang and we also meet the
vicious terracons the villains are sent
by the malicious planet-sized
Transformer Unicron who desires the
maximal's powerful transwarp key his
plan to use its space-time portal powers
to Journey Across the Universe and feed
on even more planets unfortunately for
Unicron his plans are thwarted now
trapped in his current Galaxy Unicron
since Scourge out into the cosmos to
track it down for him the big question
here that might come to mind is why
Scourge and the terror cons can
transverse the universe without the
transwarp key but Unicron can't he's
supposedly more powerful than all of
them combined couldn't he theoretically
visit and feed on any Planet Scourge
searches for the key rise of the beasts
doesn't directly address this quandary
but the most likely explanation is that
unicron's power is more limited than it
seems perhaps moving through space
requires too much energy without
guaranteed inner John awaiting him when
we first meet Noah Diaz and Transformers
rise of the beasts he's in route to
interview for a security job however his
interview is canceled after the Man In
Charge checks Noah's military record and
speaks with his former Co who claims
that he was unreliable in the Army Noah
protests claiming that he had a lot
going on at home because of his little
brother's health condition however we
don't ever get any more explanation than
that did he go AWOL to help Chris at
some point you'd think that if he did
his Old Co would have had a lot more bad
to say about him so what then was he
just distracted always calling home to
check in on his brother it's hard to
imagine how such Behavior would stick in
a Commander's mind so negatively
regardless Noah's Army experience
clearly comes in handy he handles
himself impressively well during the
final battle and his Tech savviness is a
Big Boon to his new robotic friends
Noah gets swept up into the Autobots
Crusade when he tries his hand at Grand
Theft Auto and unintentionally picks
Mirage as the car to steal it's actually
Noah's friend reek who chooses the
Target and if you stop to think about
the robbery doesn't really make all that
much sense from the dialogue we do get
it seems that reek was tipped off by
another contact that the Porsche was
ripe for the picking but as Noah enters
the garage to jack it he passes by a
number of equally fancy cars why are
they targeting Mirage specifically it's
never really explained but there are a
few possible explanations first and
foremost the Porsche is probably the
fastest car in the garage and therefore
the easiest one to get away in reek also
has a line about how long it's been
sitting there which could indicate that
no one would miss it for some time last
and most fun it could be Destiny if
you're a long time Transformers fan
you'll know that Optimus Prime and crew
put a lot of faith in fate and divine
Duty maybe Noah was simply called to be
exactly where he was supposed to go oh
I'm here because I got in the car the
the timeline of the Transformers movies
is in a word messy Bumblebee and Rise of
the beasts ostensibly take place in the
same continuity as the Michael Bay films
but there are a lot of plot holes that
confuse that chronology in Rise of the
beasts the Autobots are stranded on
Earth following the events of Bumblebee
and Optimus Prime blames himself the
discovery of the transwarp key gives him
hope that they can return home to
Cybertron but that plan ultimately falls
through there are a few confusing things
here for starters the Autobots arrive on
Earth from space during the 2007 film so
if all seven movies are indeed in the
same timeline they'd have to leave and
return somewhere between 1994 and then
second optimus's desire to return home
while understandable seems a bit strange
the whole reason they left Cybertron in
the first place is because they lost the
war to the Decepticons going home would
surely be dangerous as there's no reason
to think their enemies wouldn't still be
there the simple explanation for these
discrepancies is well plot holes but
that's not too satisfying so what else
could explain it we know that the
transwarp key allows for travel through
both space and time so maybe Optimus
wants to go back to an earlier version
of Cybertron before the war that still
doesn't explain them all being gone at
the start of the original Transformers
but hey continuities were made to be
broken right Noah Elena and the Autobots
traveled to Peru in search of the other
half of the transwarp key after
discovering that it's no longer in its
original resting place the group is
attacked by Scourge and the terror cons
they battle it out on a winding Mountain
Road but the fight is disrupted by air
razor who destroys the bridge between
Optimus and Scourge to allow the
Autobots to escape your first time
through it might seem like a bit of a
plot hole that Scourge doesn't
immediately just jump the Gap and
continue chasing Optimus after all he's
a giant robot so a little fire surely
isn't enough to scare him off in
retrospect though it's pretty obvious
that Scourge lets the Autobots get away
since they don't have the key he has no
reason to kill them yet instead his plan
is to corrupt air razor and use her as a
beacon so that he can track the group
down to the Keys relocation and to his
credit the plan works perfectly what's
more confusing is why airaser doesn't do
something about her infection before it
consumes her when Elena asks about her
injury air razor says that Scourge
leaves a Mark when he hurts you
suggesting that she understands the
nature of the wound and yet she simply
Waits until the corruption takes hold of
her mind thus jeopardizing the entire
Mission perhaps the infection begins
influencing her behavior the second it
hit her in the sky perhaps the most
confusing thing in all of Transformers
rise of the beasts is the actual
chronology of the maximals and the
Autobots the maximals are hunted by
Unicron to their home planet which the
evil God quickly devours as they make
their escape using the transwarp key
they arrive on Earth and befriend a
human tribe in Peru there they remain in
hiding until 1994 but then we learned
that Optimus primal is named after
Optimus Prime meaning that the maximals
are successors not predecessors to the
Autobots how does that work well it
isn't exactly explained but in essence
it means that the maximals traveled back
through time since the transwarp key is
said to possess time travel capabilities
it makes sense that their Voyage to
Earth could have also launched them deep
into the past I am a maximum a warrior
for both your past and future this also
fits with the story of the original
Beast Wars Transformers cartoon and toy
line in that timeline the maximals were
descendants of the Autobots who
journeyed from Cybertron to a
prehistoric Earth Via transwarp Travel
in pursuit of the evil Predacons there
are still some confusing bits however
how were Scourge and the terror cons
able to travel from the future to 1994
Earth without a transwarp key of their
own and as all this temporal meddling
mean that we're now officially in a
different timeline than the Michael Bay
films thus explaining some of the other
plot holes the first big battle in
Transformers rise of the beasts takes
place at night around the museum where
Elena works the Autobots face off
against the terracons and get their
metallic rears handed to them with
bumblebee even temporarily fighting the
dust despite all the explosions and the
length of the fight however no one seems
to notice this is a recurring issue in
the film and unfortunately not every
instance can be explained away why
doesn't anyone else wake up and see
mirage at Chris and Noah's window this
is the Big Apple after all the city that
never sleeps it's one of those confusing
moments that we probably just aren't
supposed to think about while we're at
it it's equally curious that no one
seems to notice the portal opened by
Elena's half of the transwarp key the
device seems to be activated by her
Museum scanner technology but its energy
apparently can't be seen by humans and
it shuts off as soon as the terracons
attack if you've seen any of the Michael
Bay Transformers movies you are probably
confused after seeing bumblebee get
brutally murdered by urge in Rise of the
beasts you also probably saw his final
Act Resurrection coming a mile away
Optimus primal shows Optimus Prime a bed
of Rich latent inner John near the human
village where the maximals live they
rest bumblebee there but Primal explains
that since the inner John isn't active
it won't be enough to revive him only a
massive amount of energy could energize
the Energon of course that's what ends
up happening after Scourge uses the
transworth key to open a portal Unicron
begins to pass through into Earth's
atmosphere as he does he blasts the
planet with some kind of scanning Ray
presumably to prepare the inner John for
his consumption this move has the
unintended side effect of juicing bee
back to life this chain of events poses
some other questions about how life for
a Transformer actually works we know
that every cybertronian has a spark
powered in part by Energon we call it a
spark it contains our life force and our
memories
and we call it a soul but if one of them
can be fully dead for days and still get
revived anything seems possible
during the final battle of Transformers
rise of the beasts Mirage tries to take
Scourge on by himself to allow Noah and
Elena to get to the key Mirage fights
valiantly but ultimately loses
sacrificing himself in the end to
protect Noah Mirage takes blast after
Blast from scourge's Cannon until it
seems that all the life has been drained
out of him but in a strange twist he has
just enough power left to turn himself
into an exosuit for Noah to Pilot is it
very cool yes does every kid who loves
Transformers want exactly that thing to
happen to them hell yeah but how does it
actually you know work Mirage isn't
quite dead because he's fixed up later
in the rise of the piece mid-credit
scene without the use of powered up
Energon however he clearly doesn't have
enough strength to do much on his own
the film foreshadows that he can turn
himself into a weapon for humans when he
gives Noah a piece of himself as a
blaster when you think about it his
Power Rangers form is just a more
dramatic static version of that okay
let's talk about that thing that happens
at the end after helping the autobots
and maximals save Earth from Unicron
Noah returns to Brooklyn and goes for
another security job interview this time
however things aren't what they seem the
man who interviews him agent Burke is
actually an operative and recruiter for
GI Joe yes that GI Joe
go the implication seems clear Paramount
and Hasbro are intending to finally make
a Transformers and GI Joe crossover
movie talks of a crossover something
that has happened numerous times in the
animated series and Comics have
circulated for years however now seems
like a weird time to make good on them
the last attempt at rebooting the GI Joe
film franchise was 2021's Snake Eyes
which received poor reviews overall the
Michael Bay Transformers movies also
asserts that humans and Autobots didn't
form a proper relationship until the
2010s or so so what does all this mean
we'll have to wait and see but with
multiverses and crossovers All the Rage
in Hollywood right now there's no doubt
that Paramount can find a way to throw
these two huge Brands together on the
big screen
foreign
thank you